welcome to cloud on air Google clouds
live webinar says we are hosting live
webinars every Tuesday this February
I am submersible crazy I live product
marketing for data analytics and we are
joined by Eric Schmidt hi I'm Eric
Schmidt I'm a developer advocate in the
Google cloud platform team and I spend
most of my time on data analytics and
data science workflows great and we are
going to talk about love what's a better
day than the day before Valentine's Day
we're talking about love especially if
you are in love and this topic is about
human emotions and how do you understand
human emotions applying algebra to
determine human emotions and we're going
to talk about research work by dr.
robert plutchik in this field but we're
going to talk about how do we apply
motion arithmetic in business and make
it real to delight our customers in that
context we're going to talk about Google
Cloud State analytics and data science
platform and then we are going to do a
real demo we're going to do real coding
Eric we are okay that's great let's hope
it all goes well with that let's talk
about love love has been one of the most
on Utah poq that I can ever remember and
I think that's true for for many many
decades and centuries like we have great
poets who have defined loves we have
great philosophers and most recently
evolutionary biologists talking about
love as the evolutionary necessity so
it's an interesting topic top of mind
for many people and we have been
discussing this in the context of
philosophy poet psychology and we define
love is equal to trust plus joy and how
do we come to this equation yeah so
that's the fun right let's get started
so the psychologists have been trying to
understand love and in human emotions
for tickets and one of the most cited
work in this space is from dr. robert
plutchik who came up with this very
interesting model of human psychology
called the will of emotion and what it
does it allows us to come with resultant
emotion based on underneath nuanced
emotions so for example as for his model
love equals to trust plus joy or equals
to feel blossom as
and 10 we have contempt which is anger
plus disgust but let's look at the model
the way the to interpret this model is
you have an ordinal listing of human
emotions throughout this model and the
model the emotions which are at the very
central piece of this model are the most
intense ones so if you see admiration
terror amazement grief these are very
intense human emotions and as you try to
move outside of the will cross the
petals the intensity of those emotions
come down and if you add the two
emotions in the adjacent petals you get
the resultant emotion in between the
petals so for example if we zoom into
this particular aspect of the will joy
plus Trust is equal to love and
similarly if we see or it's a state of
terror and amazement and when we got to
know that we're going to talk about
psychology in a live webinar it gave me
a bit of a terror but then we got to
know me a lot of people listening to us
that's a huge piece of measurement so
we're in a state of are pretty much good
with that let's talk about what does it
all mean
right and for you for your businesses
and so this is emotional arithmetic and
it's extremely important to understand
that today's customer feedbacks about
product about experiences are getting
really nuanced it's not just ok to
understand the sentiment of a customer's
dialect or a customer's written piece of
text we need to understand what the
customer is actually trying to convey
and and that's when we are going to get
the the juice of that comment or the or
the the talktrac and be able to not have
offered them something really really
interesting let's look at a real sample
so this is from our demo that we are
going to do later today this is a
product review from one of our customers
who is talking about one of the beauty
products that the person has bought from
the the e-commerce side and the the
person talks about that the product was
great the person got a free sample of it
the experience was great but then the
pricing was not as poor the customer
expectation and at the very end the
person is hopeful and and hopefully the
the company is going to correct the
pricing and make it a really good deal
for the customer in this this one feels
like there's like a there's polar
opposites here right exactly
so if you just do a simple sentiment
analysis on this piece of text you will
see there are a bunch of positive
sentiments flowing in the product is
created and the company has done a great
job and then we have a bunch of negative
sentiments that are going in so the
simple sentiment analysis is not going
to give us great details but if you go
and apply our emotional will the will of
emotions you will see there are nuanced
emotions playing throughout the text
there is a level of anticipation there
is a level of joy and Trust like this is
great I found the sample to be working
really well and then there are levels of
negative emotions throughout the text
like the pricing was not right there was
a level of anger and disgust so if we
apply the the will of emotion model here
to understand how we can delight this
customer if you see the person has
anticipation and join and if I if I
merge these two I see a lot of hope and
and there is a level of anticipation
that the customer has and connecting the
price may convert this customer into a
great ambassador for the product so with
that let's talk about real-life examples
of where we can apply the emotional
arithmetic and an understanding analyze
them online retail we are going to show
the demo and talk about how we apply
there but say for example gaming
analytics a lot of companies who are
providing gaming titles the gamers are
all the time very vocal about their
experience with these games and if we
can understand their emotions we will be
able to offer them more personalized
gaming experiences and marketing and
overall is trying to be more relevant to
the intended audience right so it has
huge application in the field of
marketing analytics try to making sure
that the campaigns and the content are
as per the audience's needs now if you
try to analyze customers emotions in
real-time and they're coming from
millions of your customers you can't do
it manually
no your example is great you showed us
one but how do we do this with millions
and millions of comments over millions
of
yeah and then it pretty much becomes
something get a problem for all of us
right and here is what a Google cloud
has to offer in the in the data
analytics space and we make it really
simple for our customers because our
data analytics platform is serverless
so what it means is basically for you to
build emotional analytics model apply
machine learning understand human
emotions and then apply our learning
into our product personalization you can
do this pretty much into and without
thinking about any infrastructure
capacity planning load balancing nothing
of that sort because everything else
those infrastructural needs are taken
care of by the platform and and as an
analyst you can just simply focus on
doing your data analytics and we're
going to talk about all these tools in
the context of the demo now the first
thing in the data analytics stack is the
data management platform where you store
all your customer feedbacks the emotions
in real time as they come in and our
offering in this space is Google
bigquery now bigquery is different it is
a data warehouse it's an enterprise data
warehouse but it was designed for an ml
first-world if you look at the evolution
of data warehouses over the course of
last many years data warehouses were
initially designed for a bi first
reporting first batch paradigm and now
as companies are increasingly investing
in science workflows and and building
machine learning models from their most
important data sets the data warehouse
is did to live up to that expectation
and that's what exactly bigquery does so
the first thing is bigquery is is
massively scalable so whether you
analyze your customer feedback from a
few hundred customers or millions of
customers the same system is going to
support your analysis needs it is very
simple to use it supports an sis equal
you can you can write queries in the
language that you already know and it
supports real-time data analysis like
data warehouse we typically relate to
the batch paradigm but bigquery supports
real-time streaming inserts and we're
going to show that how it works and it's
it's encrypted durable it kind of checks
all the boxes that we needed in
more near warehouses system so with that
it's almost time for the corner let's
make it real
great thanks up and I want to say hey
happy Valentine's Day
thank you very much everyone all right
so as we get into the demo we need to do
some some pre-work yeah because you just
can't go build a an online site or a
data warehouse unless you go and get
data and you ingest data and start doing
some analysis so the first thing that I
want to talk about is if you wanted to
go do analysis emotional analysis over
comments and orders etc you're gonna
have to go get data from various systems
your CRM system billing point-of-sale
etc and you may use you know a myriad of
different tools so we work with lots of
companies and the the average rate you
know right now is that most companies
use around 30 different tools to do
ingestion transformation analysis etc if
your goal is to get a holistic view of
customers you end up having to use lots
of tools over lots of different systems
one of the tools that we used for this
demo is Google Cloud dataflow what
dataflow enables you to do is to point a
job a graph of instructions at some data
source read from that source provide a
set of transformations maybe you want to
read user comments and you want to parse
out all the words or you want to load
your line items and join that to some
catalog information it doesn't really
matter you just go ahead and point it
out the source run your transformations
and then load your data to some
destination like bigquery the key here
is that this is completely service and
it is optimized for embarrassingly
parallel lized operations say like
reading a hundred million user comments
and then loading them into bigquery
so I use dataflow as my step one to go
ahead and read data from all of my
sources with this I was able to then
quickly get some high-level views of the
the data using a data studio which is a
service product it's free as well that
you can use to build real-time
interactive dashboards so this dashboard
is on top of the demo called you look
marvelous we're going to show you that
here in a minute
this view is showing me some high-level
sales information you know demographics
where my sales coming from what's the
difference between say online sales and
in-store sales here's another view that
we quickly built which is how do
products purchase Affinia ties so if
people are buying product a and they
also buy product B what's the likelihood
that they would also buy product C so I
could build a simple recommendation
based on basket analysis so I was
quickly able to go from say no data to
ingesting data to quickly visualizing it
and for this demo what I want to do is
kind of flip the analysis instead of
focusing on just the customer view or
the the product in terms of the the
sales aspect of it I want to understand
why did they buy a product yeah was it
effective would they buy it again
because ultimately the more I can learn
about the users behavior around the
journey that they took to buy a
particular product I could potentially
influence a new purchase a new user
that's coming to my site so how do
things work today so SAP you showed that
that example of reading one user comment
and this is what we're gonna show you in
the demo how things work today is
usually go into a site you would type in
sums a free search or maybe look at the
the taxonomy of that site you're trying
to find a product so maybe I'm trying to
find some cream for an acne problem and
I'm gonna get a bunch of search results
that are ranked on that site typically
by most popular buy price etc and I
start looking at their ratings and then
I look at comments and I keep doing this
process over and over again and it might
take me 2530 minutes for me to decide
whether or not I'm gonna buy this
product now so let's play a game SAP you
showed the one that you previously
scored right in this case we don't have
any of the dramatic struggled to times
skin definitely etc etc this is where us
as humans we end up spending the our
time and also emotional energy to figure
out is this common a good comment for me
in order to
a purchasing decision so what if we
showed you the results on that site that
were ranked by sediment and
effectiveness versus top-selling we can
potentially show you products that are
more appropriate for you higher in the
rank and then what if we showed you
comments once you were looking at a
product that we're more appropriate for
the product that you were looking at so
we could ultimately shrink down the the
overall kind of purchase time and we
could also provide you a more effective
cycle to influence the best possible
purchase so now that we understand the
context let's get into the demo the
first thing I want to show you is our
you look marvelous site this is a fake
demo built with fake products but these
products actually exists in the world
world I just anonymized all of them so
here I'm gonna go ahead and search for
skincare and treatments and blemish and
acne so I'm gonna go out and do a search
and you'll see that the sort order up
here is called my you look marvelous
score now typically this may be shorter
by price or social popularity but now I
have this you look marvelous storm and
you can see right here this product the
sale holid still max treatment has a 47%
you look marvelous score now take a step
back in like well forty seven percent
its that sounds low but it's the second
ranked top product so if I go ahead and
I click into this it's going to go out
and retrieve all the product information
for that particular product pull it back
here's the product this is what it says
it's good for and I'll start scrolling
down and you can see that this product
has an overall rating of four point two
four that sounds pretty good yeah right
it's got a hundred and five five-star
ratings and you can kind of see the
distribution of the other ratings so
right here if you're just looking at
ratings you'd probably be influenced
like yeah this feels pretty good this
may be a good product for me but what
we've also done on the you look
marvelous site is we've taken all of the
underlying comment information and ran
it through our emotional analysis
workflow that's a SAP was talking about
and now you can see the distributor
of emotions so you can start making
decisions like well there's a lot of
positivity around this and a lot of
people loved it a lot of people are you
know say 3% are showing anticipation but
there's also a decent amount of
negativity all right and in the real
world nothing's going to be perfect
you're always going to have products
that have some type of distribution
between positive and negative and then
various aspects of emotional rating and
the last thing to show you here is the
comments so these first three comments
we selected them based on some
psychological knobs that we built to
determine what comments are the most
positive and are also the most
information dense so as a potential
purchaser this is where we spend a lot
of time we're reading those comments
trying to figure out is this the best
comment for me what happens if you
didn't have to do that you know on the
you look marvelous site you don't these
comments for the comments that are the
most appropriate from an emotional
aspect related to the products reported
goals as well as the comments that have
the most information density inside of
them that's so kind of keep that in mind
so this is kind of how we built this you
look marvelous score and how we try to
improve the overall shopping experience
let's look at how we did that so I
talked a little bit about getting data
into bigquery using Google Cloud
dataflow I'm going to go ahead and run
this query you can see these are all my
tables over here and my you look
marvelous data warehouse so I have
comments line items locations orders etc
and this query that I'm writing right
now is looking at a few gigs worth of
data so it took just under 15 seconds
and I scanned one-and-a-half gigs of
data what this query did was it's a it's
a relatively big query nope no pun
intended I'm taking all of my orders
joining them to all the line items and
then all the line items to all the
product information and then all the
comments for all those products right so
three different joints
millions and millions of rows and I'm
trying to calculate the top 100 selling
products based on sales which is
something people normally think about
like why what are my top 100 selling
products are you making money am I
making money yeah what products are
making money but what I wanted to know
was I want to rank those top 100
products also based on the average word
count and in the comments so I have
millions and millions of comments I want
to know the average of word count for my
top 100 selling products so you can see
that product ID starting with 4 1 7 has
an average word count of 688 and if I
look at my last product in the lists
starting with 5 2 3 it has an average
word count of 182 so it's a pretty big
spread yeah and you'll see why this is
important a minute the point here is
once you have your data into bigquery
you can express any type of query that
you run that you want and you don't have
to worry about indexing partitioning etc
you literally low data right query yeah
period so now that I've showed you how
to build a big query inside of bigquery
let's go through a data analysis and
data science journey to build that you
look marvelous score I'm going to flip
over to another service product this is
Google Cloud Data Lab it is in essence a
optimized ipython environment that helps
you interact with Google cloud resources
as well as any other resource that you
would use inside of ipython so here on
this notebook is focused on building
that you look marvelous score its am I
going to do that
emotional mining here yes we're gonna go
from basically raw product view down to
what is that score and how do you figure
out what comments to filter so the first
thing you look at inside of a data lab
is we have these magic functions you see
this sequel and then module products
here I'm defining a simple query and
whenever I run this query it will go out
push down the query to bigquery and
return those results and I can easily
take sequel results and convert them
into
and ass data frames which is the area
that I'm more comfortable with like I
love sequel I love writing queries in
inside a big query etc I want to get
this data inside of pandas dataframes so
I can quickly do things like basic
looking at descriptive analysis and tops
of it on top of the data so I went out I
queried all of my products and I want to
look at their average star rating
alright the thing that you we were
influenced before so here's all the
products in my catalog and you can sign
if you see things that are tightly
clustered and the we at the 50th
percentile were about 4.2 70 % about 4.4
now whenever I was doing an analysis and
by the way this data is real this struck
me I was like oh I sell products that
people like overall like you see it is
very very tightly distributed like if I
didn't care about the products that I
was selling you'd probably see you know
some outliers you know further down in
the ratings as a customer if I was using
ratings as a mechanism to disambiguate
one product from another this is that
you're headed down a bad path right but
any choices there's too many choices
right they all look the same so the next
thing I did was I took all of my user
comments for those products and I ran
them through the Google cloud natural
language API and I'll flip over to that
real quickly here's the product page and
you can go ahead and test this with any
comments that you want I pasted it in a
comment and I hit analyze and you can
see that the Google Cloud natural
language API will provide you sentiment
at the document level as well as at the
sentiment level so you can see that
distribution that SAP was talking about
before it also picks out the entities
like this is skin cream here is the
sentiment against that entity and it
also provides you the syntax tree so if
you wanted to do some brute force
lexical processing on this you could say
hey I want to look at the top number of
verbs or I want to look at noun phrases
or I want to look at the relationships
of a one sec one syntax element from
another so you get all of this
information back from the cloud natural
language 8 API and I can use dataflow to
ingest them into my data warehouse so
now instead of just looking
scores ratings I'm now looking at
sediment so I run a slightly bigger
query and this is what the distribution
of sediment looks like for those
products and again whenever I was doing
this was like oh well in this case
humans are doing the right thing so I
know I have very tight clustering that's
in the positive range so around say
everything's you know 50% towels around
point nine or one which is good overall
there is a strong positive sentiment for
the products that I'm selling so if we
go ahead and pivot this right if you
were the product if you were the owner
of this company you're like hey this
graph makes me feel good three four five
stars up until the right you know I
don't sell any garbage I don't have any
star ratings and one and two but as a
customer you're not buying the entire
catalog you're trying to buy one product
so that product that I just showed you
on the you look marvelous site is this
product right here so how do you start
to disambiguate between say three four
and five star ratings that the the
average is in standard deviation
especially between four and five star
ratings they're almost the same so again
this data isn't really going to help you
as a customer so the next thing I did is
I I needed more data and I went and I
used an open source library called
Scirocco that helps you calculate scores
for the wheel of emotions that SAP was
talking about so I ran all of my
comments through Scirocco and now I have
a much wider dataset to look at in
essence I can write a bigger query you
see now I am selecting all these
emotions and I'm gonna go ahead and use
a slightly different visual technique
here I just have a meat map where I have
the ratings on the vertical and I have
the emotions on the horizontal and what
you see here your I kind of naturally
gravitates towards you know up into the
right here's what the most kind of
density is around those those raw scores
so I see a lot of joy acceptance
surprise this is good this is what you'd
expect but if I start looking left I'm
like wait a minute why is there fear in
in some some sadness showing up in this
product you know I did it yeah it with
that it was highly
and whenever I did this journey I was
like haha I can go dumpster dive on you
know even more data but I had to take a
steps back saying well I'm trying to
build a better ranking system for these
products now I did do that analysis so
you know yes so people were fearful that
they're not going to be able to afford
the product cuz they got the product as
a sample so they got it from a friend as
a sample it was free and then it's
working for them but now they're fearful
that they may not be able to to buy it
or they're saddened because the product
doesn't necessarily provide the
packaging doesn't provide the ability to
get all the product out of it there are
all types of reasons why the emotion
would pop up here now with this
information I now have the basis to
start building a better sort order for
my comments and products just for the
heck of it I ran a much bigger query so
this is Scirocco the emotion analysis
across all products across all comments
so you can see like overall you know up
you know in the top right quadrant
people like my products but there's a
lot of fear and guilt and sadness etc
that I may want to go dispatch to see my
product quality folks to say hey go for
God why not
what's going on here right now once I
had this data I went back to the
customers because we actually did this
with the customers we work with it's
like what would you want to show like if
you know the emotional makeup of these
comments what would you want to show and
they said we want to show customers
comments that are the most objective in
essence the most information dense
related to the product so we did some
research and it turns out there's an
inverse relationship between objectivity
and emotion so I try to prove that so I
went wrote a fairly complex query in
bigquery so I'm basically pushing down
this analysis and what I wanted to do
was find the top two comments per star
rating that were the most emotional so
here's the answer to that I love love
love I can't keep going on how much I
love this product I love this gel etc
etc this is a highly emotional comment
and you start reading it and you're not
really getting any objective information
about the product and you can see how
verbose these are
in essence a lot of these are a waste of
time if you're going to show them to the
end-user
so we prove that and then if we want to
get to objectivity what would this look
like if I pull it out all the emotion so
I write basically take that same query
and I reverse it now these are the most
objective comments in 5 4 3 2 1 so I
can't say enough about how much I love
this black line or hydrates without a
greasy feeling absorbs into skin quickly
and is lightweight this is a great
comment
it's information rich and it talks to
the properties of the program yeah so
with this I now have a way to go ahead
and start determining what comments I
want to show for particular product and
the idea here was whenever we're working
with our customers they said well we
just don't want to show all positive
comments the first one we show is going
to be the most positive and the most
objective the second one would be
slightly it would be the most positive
with a little bit of emotion so you kind
of have a you know have a sense of like
yeah this isn't just a robot that's
talking about something and then if I
want to show negative emotion I want to
show emotion around things that I can
control I can't control if people are
angry about packaging right because I
don't control the packaging but I could
help them if they're control if their
emotion is say coming from fear maybe
about pricing or something like that so
once you have that data you can start
playing with the knobs in terms of what
you actually want to show all right so
now we have this score we have this
basis score and you can use you can
weight it however you want but we didn't
stop there
and the next thing that we wanted to
look at was could we determine some
additional information about a commenter
as well as a user on a site to
potentially match them with comments
that were more appropriate for them
demographically so the question would be
well what could we look at well what
cities you know did they register from
etc what types of products that we buy
what we want to look at was age range so
in the cosmetics space because medics
across age ranges they behave
differently and people talk about them
differently and in our data set we had
20% of our users who had self-identified
into an age range you know basically you
know 18 to 26 27 to 35 etc so the
question was could we analyze that data
to see if there was a difference between
how say a baby boomer communicates
versus how a millennial communicates and
if you could see those differences then
we could build a second knob to say well
we only want to show baby boomers
comments from baby boomers and we only
want to show Millennials comments for
Millennials so how would we do that I'm
going to flip over to a another data lab
notebook this is a notebook that we
built to do age classification so using
very similar techniques I started my
journey by polling in a raw data set
from bigquery in essence all the
comments and the buckets that users were
in so I only had 20% of my users head
classified age or her had talked about
age so I'm trying to basically project
and classify to the 80% of population
here I'm using Karis sitting on top of
tensorflow
as well as bigquery and I'm gonna go
ahead and move down to the the bulk of
my the model that I built the idea here
is that for every comments I have n
number of words and I'm using an
embedding model I'm basically saying for
the top 100 were the first 100 words in
that comment I want to identify the most
closest words to them so it's a
technique code embedding so the Safa
fused the word like and i use the word
love those words are fairly close if you
use the word hot and I use the word cold
those words are fairly far apart so the
idea here is that if we can cluster
comments based on the distance between
those words we could start seeing like
yeah there's a difference between how
Millennials and boomers communicate so I
go ahead and I run
my my training data in order to my
training data to train this model and
there's some interesting things that pop
out of it so you can see here that I'm
going head and I'm calling out to
bigquery and I pulled back 21,000
comments so I'm gonna train on 16,000 of
them I try to distribute these the
groups between Group one and group two
Millennials and boomers I try to keep
the distribution even so I'm not
creating some type of bias and for those
16,000 some comments it found 14300 two
unique words which is good this is how
I'm going to create my embeddings one of
the problems I ran into is that humans
unfortunately don't spell correctly 100%
of the time so out of the 14,000 words
3,200 of these words had in all
embeddings so that people spelled
moisturizer incorrectly or break out etc
so and basically I kind of taken the
fidelity of the data that I had I have
higher fidelity but I has I have less I
have less data to analyze so I was kind
of concerned at this point I'm like oh
no you know humans can't spell that's
okay
they kept going I kept training and with
the data even with this the quality
issues I had within 62% I can accurately
predict whether or not you're a
millennial or boomer
so here's here's a good example so my
predicted label was one which is a
millennial the actual label was one that
says I'm a teenager so I just started
breaking out after I wash my face etc
now in this case like teenager is a
really really good hint like if you see
I'm a teenager t net cetera you know the
clustering is going to is be way of my
way more efficient right this one boomer
to boomer you kind of read it you're
like well obviously there's some type of
information some type of pattern within
that text that classified them as a
boomer and the great part is is that you
don't necessarily have to go and
decompose why it is you just know that
you accurately predicted and I think if
with with some more tuning techniques
and cleaning up the these these bad
embeddings up here I could probably get
this to about 70% right which is awesome
so now I have the ability to tune a knob
and say
whether or not you're a millennial or
boomer and I also have knobs to tune
whether or not you want to see emotional
you know or non emotional objective or
not objective comments so using those
two techniques if you come back to the
site this is ultimately those two
techniques are ultimately wet-dry what
is driving what is rendered on this site
on the back end what we don't show in
this demo there's a another seminar that
has been done on the it's called the
marketing analytics starter pack is
showing you how to test whether or not
what you built is effective using Google
Analytics so you can imagine if a user
read these these two comments are
clicked on them and made a purchasing
decision through Google Analytics I
could track all that that clickstream do
some basic a B testing and saying yes
this model that we came up with this way
it's just the most effective one to
drive sales all right let's get back
into the slides and wrap up
real quick note so the Sirocco library
that I used is Java base you can go out
it's open source you can find it in
github and it can talk about and it
talks about how you can use various
indexing techniques and how you can
leverage it with dataflow but you don't
have to use it with dataflow if you're
running this inside of Apache spark or
something else or maybe you could use it
you would even want to run it locally on
your own machine although that wouldn't
be great for a big data problem so I
encourage you to go out and look at
Scirocco if you're trying to look at the
emotion analysis if you just need
sentiment sentiment information and/or
the lexical graph go and use cloud
natural language processing it is a
great technique if you need that that
higher level information so what do we
show you the journey was go ahead and
ingest the fire bigquery it's super
simple you basically say create data set
go ahead and low tables and you can
either do that in batch or streaming
mode big query enables you to ingest
data in real time up to a hundred
thousand records per second per table
and then go ahead and do some quick
analysis inside of data lab or inside of
data studio we talked about doing some
enrichment so you could use the cloud
natural language API you could also use
our vision API you could do any type of
enrichment technique that you want using
data flow or another ETL tool and then
we get into the analysis piece so you
could do something like with Sirocco you
could write your own analysis algorithms
and then once you get into feature
development and modeling you can do that
inside of a data lab you can do inside
of ipython you can do it inside of our
it doesn't matter to go ahead and create
the types of features that you want in
order to build a model and then finally
if you need to go ahead and train and
serve this at scale you can go ahead and
use cloud machine learning engine so we
went through a bunch but this is in
essence how we got back to this
architecture but now this has been
contextualized in a retail scenario but
this would work in any type of scenario
this could be for Life Sciences that
could be for financial services it could
be for doing analysis over sports yeah
so with that SAP and I want to thank you
for your time absolutely we've kind of
gone from zero to emotions and we
understand how to quantify love and with
that we're gonna flip over to the live
Q&A I didn't know this one look at that
with it this way tell me when that's
good but straighten it out other way
good
[Music]
so we talked about e-commerce site and
in real businesses you will have like
hundreds of thousands of customers
giving comments on your website and
expressing their emotions and sentiment
how can I use cloud natural language API
to score lots and lots of comments sure
so there are several techniques the one
that we talked about was ultimately you
want to do this in the most parallelized
fashion as possible because you have
lots of things and if you did them
serially it would take you lots of time
so using a product say like cloud
dataflow or another ETL tool so maybe
you wanted to use a spark or just a
straight MapReduce job you could go
ahead and build a graph that will then
go ahead and parallel lies the analysis
of each one over those comments and
that's the technique that we used here
we just use the cloud NLP API and then
build a function that says okay input
comment call function and then you
paralyze that so you could effectively
do a job that would say take 24 hours in
total you could run that job in 6
minutes of clock time yes right and what
if I need to do something more custom
than what natural language API offers
yeah good question so so caught on up
you as we showed you you can get
document and sentence level sentiments
you can also understand the the syntax
tree if you need more there are a bunch
of already open source libraries out
there like Scirocco and these in some
cases play well with each other so in
fact with Sirocco I was using the output
of cloud NLP in order to drive Scirocco
or you could build your own classifier
you could say build something that was
more focused on identifying the subject
of of that emotion if you will
and the the the point being is that
anything that you do custom you can then
load it back into the data
transformation or ETL system that use it
you're using say for example like cloud
dataflow yeah can we apply the same
technique to do like Twitter analytics
like customers are talking about my
brand in social media platforms like
Twitter can I apply the same techniques
to understand the emotions in the
sentiment of the Twitter streams that
are coming yeah definitely and the the
path that that one would take is is
basically ingesting that that stream so
Twitter is a great example so if you
have access to the full firehose or
maybe even to the the Decca hose you
need to be able to go in and just and
put that data at some place in a in a
very low latent process bigquery is a
great place to do that so I can
basically go ahead and read from those
Twitter streams raw and ingest in real
time into bigquery and then turn around
and write your real time analysis on top
of it and bigquery allows you to do
streaming analytics pretty much do I
need to do any configuration to make it
happen no you literally just create a
table and start writing so that's great
yep and you should be the lab but if I
am a user and I want to use any other
tool how do I connect to bigquery to
analyze my data yes so there are two
open source libraries right now to
connect to bigquery and most recently
panda also just added native read
support so now you can just go do pandas
I read from from Google bigquery and all
the underlying connectivity etc is
handled by the library so if you're in
any type of environment that supports
pandas that will work nicely and there's
also the similar API for our Wow that's
great so no need to take like a data
export to a separate data store just
directly do it off know if you're moving
text files around like like that you've
yeah go find those libraries they're
quite easy to use so I think the the
last question we're gonna take is how do
I find more granular sentiment I think
the question is like how do I understand
emotions I think you talked about
the opens was like pretty but can we
guess he emphasized that please hurry
yeah they're in there there are other
libraries out there other than Scirocco
but in the in the case of Scirocco the
the builder of it his name's Sergei so
glencoe he's a he's a Googler and he and
I had several lunches about this topic
and he was just like yet the existing or
the analysis that the pallucci built and
the research they built was was fairly
sound like it was it was very well
received and it works well for lots of
business domains so we whenever I was
making the decision I was like I didn't
necessarily need to do more you know it
provided the right level of Grandma
granularity what I needed to do was make
sure that it was accurate in my case
overall it was so-so kind of you kind of
picked tool that you need in order to
solve the problem but you may find that
you need more granularity out there and
there are other open-source libraries
that you could use so okay that's quick
and with that we come to the conclusion
of this cloud on-air stay tuned for the
next session we are going to bring GCP
closer to you we have the next florida
ner starting from the mountain view
office life so thanks for joining Eric
and myself and we talked about love
spread the word of love and happy
Valentine's Day to all of you take care